Sarah it is
[Music]
I love my mother
so let's get after it and have a spot
good [__] bread
um I always love a good Cuomo segment
oh by the way I just got the email we uh
we I I'm shocked that I lost my appeal
really can't believe it I know well this
should make you feel better he did do it
uh well here you go that's Adam
Friedland as you can see worked or you
know no I said it puts the lotion in the
basket
I I don't want to do Bill I want to do
uh Jody Foster because I'm more dressed
like her right now
Dr Electro I played a I played a child
street walker in
in texture driver too did you see you
can tell Como who needs attention
because this whole interview I suggest
watching the whole thing he's just
making fun of him for 58 minutes Adam is
always so high oh yeah he's always so
hot dark movie Dr Lecter
it's pretty strong
you're from New York you were born in
the 70s
1970. I know at Wikipedia I saw it
hahaha
I only managed that was really good
how do you know if it's true
you gotta cut with this anti-wikipedia
crap we got an argument before the show
started it's like well you're very
righteous it's the only not very
open-minded I am pessimistic about
everything other than Wikipedia it's the
only thing that the internet did uh well
so
somebody can go on decide they're not as
big a fan of the Adam Friedland show as
everyone should be they can then just
malign your past and you're okay with
that people call my parents house
this is so good dude this is so great
it's so funny because the Guntown fans
really are ruthless and they've done a
lot of [__] to Adam
yeah I mean yeah like what do they say
my dad's like uh
we're not interested
this is a crossover I never imagined
what happened but we needed it but it's
probably my favorite thing to ever
happen
I'm on the Do Not Call List my dad my
parents are from Cape Town what is scary
cultural Evolution they've had down
there what black people are being able
to vote
this is oh my God Chris can I ask what
were you he needs attention he needs he
loves attention look I know he loves
attention we all have a little attention
now and then but like
what were you thinking like did you even
watch this [__] did you are you even
familiar with what no of course I don't
know he's not he just saw the numbers
you know he just saw the numbers
yes obviously my concern no is that they
have given the right to vote suffrage is
a very frightening concept it is so
interesting to see how something that's
so extreme can still get stopped about
the what'd you just do by the way don't
my I told my dad then you look like a
dragon all of a sudden it's like Puff
the Magic Dragon we're here and you say
you don't want to tell anybody what is
that are you just hot under the collar
before we go into your race signs he
took a [__] hit of his name you're so
great no I'm forget it now
did you see the movie contact yes if you
name me another movie Just
did this has been brilliant too because
stov left
and they rebranded right and then they
they're like yeah let's get these guests
but it was genius because nobody really
knows who the [__] Adam Freeland is
and so Nick and Nick was like we'll call
it the Adam Friedland show everyone's
just gonna see some Jewish name
and see the numbers and they'll just
come on
it's kind of brilliant these Dominica
goes he claims he's a come Town fan no
he's not he's a liar you you Chris
Cuomo's sitting there listening calm
down
like I'm half a [__] or something thank
you no thank you I don't even eat [__]
pal
[Laughter]
ette
my wife is very disappointed luckily I
have a lot of money
I love this by the way
is that okay what this yeah like this
these are very exciting I'm loving this
this is good you're my best friend
it's weird I almost should lock it in
place don't give people this option
because now like look how upset he is
okay maybe take it up with the Herman
Miller
those are expensive chairs but also
they're meant for you you have an unfair
advantage in these chairs because I'm a
little man the way that you sit you look
very comfortable in here and I'm kind of
locked into it like Fred Flintstone
where like I'm not the right shape for
the chair can I ask you a serious
question please
okay
hahaha
um Christopher Christopher Christopher
yes Mom Christopher okay Pete covet
right Peak cover Peak covet yes okay
early 2020. you're in the basement right
yes okay America is like must-see TV
this is a this guy's a hero right do you
think there were single women that saw
your muscles right and your struggle and
maybe
now when you say a little bit
do you mean you no I knew that you were
faking it to get wow Chris can I just
point out Adam's [__] yeah let's do
that Adam's [__] killing it but
he really sucks at this improv so he's
not good at it well you mean you're like
you mean like your fat girl like your
girl or you're Mary
he's just repeating words old Italian
insults with this guy he is like
he cannot think on his feet whenever he
doesn't have a producer manager he
doesn't know what to do to disparage our
president Donald Jefferson Trump but I
think there's a little bit of a deeper
truth here that you want to express and
you should feel good doing that my
sister was watching she was like oh my
God this guy's an angel now by your
sister do you mean you is he gonna do
the same joke twice do you mean you oh
my God
he sucks you suck Chris you suck no
no I get chicks bro I get magic and by
getting chicks do you mean you you
just just keeps going right back to that
hey and then he goes home he tells wife
hey honey did you watch me I was burning
him unfortunately I remember when I said
it was him like 12 times you would be
surprised you can get chicks as you say
and have felt something strange when you
were watching me uh oh
it
um now Chris I'm gonna use it are you
sure you don't mean you it's about to
get gay is this about you getting chicks
but your penis jumped a little bit when
Don Lemon was talking to you is that
what you think it'd be like I wonder
what it'd be like to be with a with a
sassy angry black guy that'd be weird
right
it's just me all right you don't wanna
Chris is the Christmas party can you
please stop saying that what I'm just
saying I missed that fig I'm just saying
uh
I come in his mouth and be like be the
[__] well I didn't feel bad for you at
all I'm like look at this [__] I
didn't say you felt look at that baby in
his nice house so there was a very
confusing thing about that I'll tell you
something serious about this although I
really do feel that lab leak you're
about to say
what what is going on
I may have well been completely we don't
know we don't have he wants to give us
the answer because you can't post
questions yeah all right then you can't
post that he is right about that it's
weird that we don't know
um my friend hold on a second how many
topics you want to throw at me at once
we don't want to do
um wait hold on it's boring I want to
talk about them I want to unpack he
literally started the conversation about
coffee it's boring I want to talk about
the mafia is that a shot at his dad I
want to unpack him one at a time okay
just because I'm Italian doesn't mean I
have insight into the mafia your father
was 100
Mafia you [__] and your brother and
you hold on wait just because I'm
Italian doesn't mean I have uh
affiliations with the mafia all right
Chris then stop acting like you're a
[__] monster that's true because it's
like he loves to play off The Stereotype
but then he doesn't like The Stereotype
he wants to beat De Niro in every one
shot in her Scorsese movie Walking to a
club handing 20s to people that's who he
wants to be is De Niro and the Irishman
but like d aged like an old man kicking
yeah but the face is Young
yeah no not that I want to talk about
1992. I want to talk about you're 22
you're at Yale probably yeah your father
yeah goes on a [__] trip yeah
I was reading this last night I was like
losing my [__] mind where'd you read
it on Wikipedia
no I read a full article about it it
only came out in 2006 I think that the
Sicilian Mafia planned an assassination
of your father this is nonsense it's
[__] yeah it is what do you mean
it's not oh I thought this was gonna be
kind of but you know this is funny it's
hilarious that was a very uncomfortable
chug this is a uh um
no no comment
what are you talking about
it's so cool let's go through each of
the things that have mattered here kovid
[__] [__] covet boring it's not about
covid it's about you and being honest I
am honest during covet
when you saw me
he won't he doesn't want to touch the
mafia thing he keeps going back to that
stupid covert thing because he doesn't
want to touch the mafia think oh no no
no no no no no hey Virgie give me that
article from 2006 about this because now
we know it's true on television
I mean we can get back to this later
because I just feel like the mafia it's
hard but you were it's hard to talk
about it Adam Friedland but I don't want
you getting hurt
oversized suit wearing Sperrys boat
shoes is [__] what a great look Adam
I love it conversation no no be honest
about yourself no you're you're
filibustering I'm filibustering you were
there this might be the toughest
interview Como's ever had were you
beating Tucker one I was largely unaware
of everything that was happening about
me during that time because I was
actually sick well early covid people
got [__] I would be pretty much asleep
or in a sweat all day long
that's because you didn't take the right
post Psychotherapy stupid armor says one
dollar I [__] you not there was a
Chinatown mob boss and Governor Mario
Cuomo's Asian Affairs office yeah we
know bro everybody knows about Como's
dad and [__] the mafia connection
everyone I was I'm not from New York and
I knew about that Mario Cuomo was
[__] deep with the mob
or a article on it this is amazing no
that's not true they used to joke about
it on SNL and [__]
yeah dude that the guardian no this is
legit man this is uh yeah they did Mafia
Planet killed Cuomo this is a seven year
old article uh Hitman says mob plan to
Ambush with men who had rifles and
explosives kosa Nostra called The Off
the attack when scale of a security
detail became apparent yeah no no this
is a [__] yep
I had no idea
of how resonant it was at the time
and an artist yeah thing was I did
because I was talking to all of the
people get completely disowned I thought
that that was going to be bad for him
get the mom my brother killed a million
people and he would not be bald would
not work for you why not
yeah I don't get back to the mafia
where that bug I mean it's not his fault
I get it but I mean
We're not gonna play the whole thing you
watch the whole thing later it's funny
but it is weird right that like that he
was trying to joke around and be funny
but that really really that rattled him
that rattled him Adam [__] unknown
unknown he stumbled into that rock a
nerve on him anything oh that's so
telling wow that is super super [__]
telling that's crazy
oh we gotta look into that I want to
look into that stuff I want to know more
about that because that now it feels
like that thing really happened right
there's no way it didn't
yeah I know well yeah again they were
they were not uh he was deep in with
them so it would make sense at some
point that maybe they wanted to yeah I
think the problem is he he said it wrong
maybe he didn't understand he should
have said they wanted to whack your
father yeah they want to whack off your
father don't you want to whack your
father don't you mean you what you mean
you want to whack me off yeah hey I'm
not gonna [__] you bro
what did Don Lemon put you up to this